rebecca bon choix on rapatrie nous
parler d'une première deux premiers
albums les soeurs
oui on connaissait les armes et gargaud
vous avez partie de la même famille mon
enveloppe que pour vous fais
habituellement et pourtant les soeurs
ware est c'est maïs ou si elles n'ont
pas la même mère mais l'ol ont le même
père
goodwin wright est aussi le père de
refus il vient de sortir un album de
berceuses sanguine de dirt les berceuses
carrément dérangeante et je vous propose
d anjou et dérangeante temps bon sens
perdu
m
je sais
il aurait
non
je me souviens
ouais
sa dernière chance et wes et les
harmonies sur une bâtisse aux lumas
magnifique on sait jamais parfois on est
qu avant de décerner laquelle et
laquelle parce que on va quand même des
voies différentes et parfois laissé
juste ensorcelant c'est pas des chansons
originales les chansons de kate
mcgarrigle mais vous avez vu d'ailleurs
là on a fait un essai pour montrer celle
de la mère et de la fille des bélugas
ces lugubres mais c'est pas sinistre
parce que c'est dans le texte c'est
vraiment des histoires sordides
histoires d'infanticide des histoires de
2,2 de commandes de commentaires à un
enfant qu'on donne en lui disant écoute
la vie c'est vraiment ça vous plaise ou
pas la peine d'être vécue mais on s'en
rend pas compte parce que l'emballage
est tellement d'où le titre sans ennahda
en concert une seule fois la semaine
prochaine au centre fille de montréal le
1er décembre
et pour noël la deuxième pièce qu'on a
entendu c'est très bel album est
vraiment bon c'est pas vraiment vous en
apercevoir que ces sordides claira
content parce que vous allez je n'ai eu
que des paroles louis walsh est un
puzzle de cette manière très bien
rebecca oui beaucoup de gens
l'attendaient les trois accords nouvel
album joie d'être gay a traversé leur
après avoir oui oui après exactement on
est dans l'amour différence est
pleinement assumée heureusement qu'elle
ait trois accords qui nous sortent du
marasme de la car l'actuel taux et
l'actualité pendant les lourdes on a
besoin des trois accords par contre en
lisant juste les titres de l'album moi
j'ai eu j'ai ressenti une grande
lassitude gp le ton nom j'ai un massage
pour toi l'esthéticienne c'est pas
faciale l'album de simon proulx l'album
solo qui est sorti cet été le premier
extrait s'il fait chaud kring bon il ya
une obsession ici le style oui il y aura
t-elle mais est-ce qu'on est allé au
bout de la blague c'est ce que je me
pose une question on écoute des extraits
de cet album
j'allais tuer
jalal est gay
la pochette est hyper kitsch aussi moi
j'aimerais vous dire que depuis que
j'aime les poussins qui objectait reçu
par le monde les jeunes le problème
parce que dès le départ les trois
accords j'ai vu au delà de l'humour du
double sens du premier degré et je pense
que les trois accords étaient vraiment
leur apogée en 2009 avec l'album dans
mon cas il y avait une superbe chanson
triste la seule triste vraiment le
bureau du médecin qui était qui était
tout à fait à propos qui raconte est
vrai une sorte de quelqu'un sans avoir
son médecin qui reçoit des mauvaises
nouvelles et c'est comme si le pendule
avait été trop loin dans le sérieux car
il faut voler dans la grosse grosse
blague en même temps j'aime beaucoup
simon proulx et moi je trouve touchant
voir poignante savoie et je peux tu as
nous élaborons il faut quand même chiant
et guy rebecca ce sont des grandes
mélodies cela dit légère d'oreilles
connaître sous peu il se targue avec cet
album d'être venus sont des années 90 il
ya des gens qui voudraient il me semble
que depuis le début vous sonnez comme on
ait eu à prendre ou à laisser
mais bon voilà rebecca on va parler à
tania de la branche oui entendu sa
reprise de formidables de stromae même
que lorsque j'étais à paris on en a
parlé on peut plus parler de la bronca
de coeur de pirate bay city allait voir
coeur de pirate à paris faisaient
l'olympia mais justement vont écouter ce
qu'on voit un lien de l'autre côté merci
hrebec merci patrice